stormy Daniels continues to epitomize
grace and class as she compares
president Trump's genitals to cartoon
fungus CNN dedicates a segment to Donald
Trump jr. I'm not talking about the
president's son and Hillary Clinton says
we need to give women accusers the
benefit of the doubt
I kid you not then the blazes Stuber
gear drops by to talk about the news and
why it matters finally the meaning of
life all that and more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
buckle up we're going below the belt
today it is gonna be a saucy saucy show
so the Brett Kavanaugh update you know
Brett Kavanaugh the absolutely
unimpeachable you know without blemish
Supreme Court nominee so they've made up
some crazy stuff about him and they're
trying to portray him as a rapist or
something to catch you up on this the
accusation came from Christine Blasi
Ford who says that 36 years ago or
somewhere there abouts when they were
drunk teenagers Cavanaugh tried to get
her shirt off at a party and she doesn't
remember where the party was or how it
came together or exactly who was there
and she's changed her story since she
first mentioned it for the first time
ever six years ago thirty years after it
allegedly happened and the other person
who says that she was in the room or the
other person who she says was in the
room calls the accusations absolutely
nuts then another person who she says
was at the party
a guy named what's-his-name
PJ Patrick Smith or Smythe he says that
he was not at the party she then said
she would testify before a congressional
hearing and now she says she won't do it
Christine Blasi for more like Christine
blase for it if you ask me am i right
because she won't to it she isn't gonna
show up now surprise surprise I wonder
why I wonder why because the accusation
is not credible regardless of what
happened or didn't happen it really now
looks like nothing like what she's
describing happened but now one person
came out on Twitter and said that she
was there and she knows about this and
she was at the high school at the time
and that he's guilty as sin this this
tweet from this person said I graduate I
graduated from Holton arms and knew both
Brett Kavanaugh and Mark judge Christine
Blasi Ford was a year or so behind me I
remember her
I signed the letter in support of her
the incident was spoken about four days
afterwards in school Cavanaugh should
stop lying owned up to it and apologized
and then so people they were running
with this the media were running and
tweeting and yeah yeah yeah and then and
then she deleted it she deleted the
tweet and then and then we now have the
latest from this is also being reported
on Twitter she
yeah I wasn't there I don't know please
don't contact me I don't want to testify
so nobody wants to testify to this
because mmm wonder why wonder why and
the Democrats are dragging it out and
out and out so before we get into how
all the politicals are reacting to this
I just want to show you the degradation
of our culture here but I want to show
you CNN's segment on Donald Trump jr. as
it were here is CNN CNN dedicated an
entire segment to the most pressing news
of the day she writes that her first
sighting of Donald Trump in 2006 in his
hotel suite in Lake Tahoe was shocking
Trump came swooping in wearing black
silk pajamas and slippers she writes
what are you doing I yelled go put some
effing clothes on she writes that he
changed and they both joked about his
hair I pointed to his hair what's going
on with this I know he said with a smile
it's ridiculous she says the two talked
about family what would your wife think
of you being here with me stormy writes
oh don't worry about that he said it's
not a big deal in any way we have
separate bedrooms
she writes Trump then brought out a
picture of Melania holding their son
Barron who was just four months old at
the time and when Daniels came out of
the bathroom she claims Trump was lying
on the bed in his underwear they had sex
she then describes his genitalia in
great detail his penis is distinctive in
a certain way she writes I'm gonna cut
it there I'm gonna cut it there I'm
gonna spare you the rest of this I don't
think I need to subject my audience to
the rest of this this went on for four
minutes that might not sound like a lot
when you think about podcasts or
whatever four minutes is an eternity on
cable news well you know I go on Fox and
Friends about once a week it usually
these hits are like two minutes maybe
you know if they give you four minutes
that is a lot of time and they spent
four minutes talking about how
distinctive it is in a certain way and
stormy said isn't CNN facts first I'm a
banana yeah they are as all bananas on
CNN that's all CNN wants to talk about
remember the apple and banana add a lot
of bananas and it is bananas
I mean this is so the next time that
they're lecturing you what we need we
have serious journalists every
journalist at CNN there because there
are a couple ostensibly not so horrible
people there they should speak out
against this this is disgraceful this is
so so disgraceful even I get it if you
want to mention the book for some reason
fine four minutes on this give me a
break
but that's all they're going to talk
about now it's xxx we're going to talk
with Stu a little bit later about about
how the sex is just dominating or
political culture but there are
incredible iron is now when it we're
getting back to Cavanaugh because that's
the that's the major story here
Democrats are coming out and force in
total hypocrisy jumping on this it is
pure hackery I actually had the
privilege of sitting down last night
with Hillary Clinton to discuss Brett
Kavanaugh that that the FBI is not
conducting an independent investigation
is conducting a background investigation
and the client if you will the requester
is the White House so the precedent that
you just referred to is the precedent
for getting the FBI to conduct an
investigation and that's what the White
House should do now you can believe
Hillary Clinton here you actually can in
a certain respect if anybody knows about
getting investigated by the FBI it is
that old crooked Crone she has been the
object of law enforcement since what the
eighties the 70s so we're going to be
speaking with Ken Starr soon I mean she
back deals in fraud and money laundering
getting getting hiding documents
stealing federal records this woman
knows what it's like to be the subject
of a federal investigation and she's
pretty good at avoiding the consequences
of that too
but then she gets into the purest
hypocrisy of them all I'm so glad was so
nice of Hillary Clinton to come on my
program last night he or she is in in
the most stunning sexual hypocrisy of
all that's what the Republicans should
be doing right now from the white house
down Pennsylvania Avenue to the Senate
give the benefit of the doubt to the
court in the country
and that means have a an investigation
that will then lead to a hearing that
will then lead to a vote if appropriate
so give women accusers the benefit of
the doubt for those of you who are not
familiar with Clinton EES they're
amazing at manipulating language because
they're both very intelligent people the
Clintons and they're amazing at
manipulating language to not just quite
get around everything so she's saying we
need to give the benefit of the doubt to
the court in the country what does that
mean
we're gonna give the benefit of the
doubt to the courts you should talk
about how great citizens united was
right if we're gonna give the benefit of
the doubt of the country she's not
talking about how great it was that they
like to Trump which is really trying to
say without saying it's give the benefit
of the doubt to women accusers but she
can't quite say that because she smeared
and slandered all of the credible
accusers against her husband for decades
Gennifer Flowers Kathleen Willey Juanita
Broderick who accuses President Trump
president from President Clinton of
raping her we spoke to one EDA Broderick
on the show she smeared them trailer
park trash dragged $100 bill through a
trailer park and this is what you get
though the bimbo eruptions she smeared
all of them so what we're now being told
is that women who have credible
accusations made in a timely manner with
evidence with witnesses against a
powerful figure
they should not be believed but a lady
who shows up five minutes ago to say
that a drunken teenager tried to take
her top off 36 years ago and she has no
witnesses and doesn't can't give any
details and won't speak that woman is to
be believed that's that I think that's
the it's obviously hypocrisy it's
obvious obviously pure hackery any time
a Democrat does this is pure hackery the
party of Jefferson reporting of Thomas
Jefferson poor Sally Hemings the party
of FDR who died in his mistress's arms
the party of JFK where do I begin how
many how many interns at once in the
Lincoln Bedroom the party of Bill
Clinton now they're lecturing us
unthreat Cavanaugh a totally
unimpeachably character are you kidding
me that's absurd
by the way I was just naming the
Democrat presidents who did this kind of
stuff let's not even get into the
senators and the congressman Ted Kennedy
it's crazy
Joe
and jumped on the bandwagon to Joe Biden
former vice president United States he
is saying with regard to the Cavanaugh
allegations quote for a woman to come
forward in the glaring lights of focus
nationally you've got to start off with
the presumption that at least the
essence of what she's talking about is
real whether or not she forgets facts
whether or not it's been made worse or
better over time
so presume that the accused is guilty
guilty until proven innocent that's what
Joe Biden is saying Joe Biden who I
don't know if you've ever googled Joe
Biden women just go down that rabbit
hole on YouTube for a while smelling
their hair you know no way Uncle Joe
guilty until proven innocent that's what
they're saying now until it's one of
them that's accused until it's keith
ellison they're not talking about keith
ellison are they woman credibly accusing
him of beating her they don't talk about
bob menendez they don't tell you no not
those guys it's pure pure hackery and we
cannot we cannot tolerate this we
shouldn't we've got to get to Stu in a
second but we should not tolerate this
as Republicans because some
conservatives are getting squishy on
this rock do that who has an interesting
perspective he is a conservative never
Trump conservative at the New York Times
he's saying basically the same thing as
Joe Biden he's saying almost the same
thing today that we should that it's
incumbent on Brett Kavanaugh unfair as
it may be to prove that he didn't do it
to prove that he wasn't there he didn't
- no it's not no it's not incumbent on
him and it's absurd for for Republicans
and conservatives to try to hem and
horns well I don't know it should Mel
maybe he's you who know and I didn't do
it no it's a totally ridiculous charge
it's pure hackery
it even if he did try to get a girl
shirt off 36 years ago first of all
there should have been some sort of
investigation and the same people who
were saying that when you commit a crime
as a teenager it shouldn't be held
against you for the rest of your life if
you come into crime as a 25 year old it
shouldn't be held against you a lot of
people on the Left don't allow them to
get away with this and first of all
there's no evidence when it comes to
Brett Kavanaugh don't allow them to get
away with this it's so important I think
there are some conservatives and
Republicans and members of the
administration who just want to get rid
of them and do someone else
evanka
according to some report which is
probably bogus but Ivanka Trump is
apparently saying that we should they
should can Cavanaugh there are people
who are saying we should we should cut
cut bait here a Jeff Flake is saying we
need to hear her out no we don't know we
don't stop it if we lose on this if we
allow them to bork Brett Kavanaugh to to
slander this guy who is apparently
spotless we're never gonna get another
judge through we can't win anything
why if we can't get Brett Kavanaugh
through we can't get anything through I
don't I don't know what we're even
running for at this point it becomes a
circus it is so much more important than
they're having us believe don't give in
on this Republicans give in on the
nutrition eat healthily any good food
but don't give in on Brett Kavanaugh
where do we go from there
first of all any guy any guy whoever is
up for any political position is dead if
an unsubstantiated claim about trying to
get a girl's top off 36 years ago with
no evidence no witnesses even though the
witness won't speak or the the accuser
won't speak if that can torpedo your
entire career every man is finished on
both sides of the aisle it's not just
affecting Republicans every guy's
finished probably most women are
finished who can survive that you can't
give in with their what they're gonna
try to say as a rule Kavanagh he's
compromised get someone else get you
know get just go for someone else come
on it's not a big deal we'll get there
are plenty of other good judge
candidates no no no no if it weren't a
big deal they wouldn't be pushing so
hard at this don't let them get away
with this it is immoral to let them get
away with this do not let them do it and
alright we that that's my important
message to all conservatives and
Republicans we've got to talk about all
the important news though like game up
'its and the ban of memes throughout
Europe and for that we bring on Stu
Bergere who is on the Glenn Beck program
he's on the news and why it matters and
there Glenn Beck guys are hanging around
the studio this week and I love Stu he's
got a great perspective so let's bring
him in Stu Wow thanks for having me
that's so an honor so well you know you
were just around here you figured out
gosh I've got five minutes ryojun
because I was on your show yesterday
yeah I have the news and why it matters
yeah I was a lot of fun that was a ton
of fun yesterday and especially in this
news cycle I'm actually beginning to
question the premise of your show yeah
which is the news matter I'm not
convinced at all we've got
thirty-five-year-old accusations we've
got the president's Mario Kart Wii I
don't I don't need any of that
it's disturbing it's very disturbing the
news and why it's disturbing is the news
my you should pay attention to something
else because there are other very
important news stories today yes I would
say after the Mario Kart and after the
most important news stories are Bert and
Ernie a well-known Sesame Street puppets
there's a big debate on between
different writers and creators of them
as to whether or not they're gay
coincidentally I don't know why this is
but in my notes for our interview
whoever taped this put a gay pride stick
around there so we have their vote or
Bert and Ernie game Bert and Ernie you
know they're a wonderful team and
they've provided us so much happiness
for so long I don't think they're gay
then here's my premise for this ok the
guy who created them said they're not
gay and is that all the other no I got
no deeper okay um
they're made of felt okay most gay
people are not made of felt now they're
made over genders your IRB right it's
something shiny right felt isn't shiny
at all true puppets don't usually have
any genitals known so it's difficult for
them to engage in any sexual you know I
don't know I've never taken clothing off
of a puppet or use some kind of brick
Aven over here I'm checking out puppet
there was an incident at a party I don't
want to go to it through an
administration yeah Miss Piggy was
involved it was not pretty but yeah
that's an interesting thing is that we
have to come up now with sexuality for
puppets uh you know for the guy I was it
was actually kind of sad the guy who who
kind of brought this to everybody's
attention he said he was a writer I
guess for many years for Bernie which I
thought they came up with all their own
material and I'm a little frustrated I
know it's all they like yeah exactly
morick Saltzman I think Marc Saltzman
and he said he always considered them
gay and he wrote them as if they were
gay and he modeled them after his own
relationship and he's gay but I thought
that was really sad because Bert and
Ernie sleep in separate beds is this guy
what what's happening at the house I'm
late I I think he's got the right idea
yeah I want to stretch out I don't need
somebody rolling over on to me and I
separate beds is fine separate
California Kings I mean yes well that's
the problem I think they had twins and
like you're an adult yeah I you know I
know you're on a kids show
I believe Bert and Ernie were full
full-grown I don't believe they're ever
getting any taller so I you know I think
that the twin bed thing was a little
rough it's just it's just like I we
can't you know Glenn's booked he's out
here two pornos book and a gin to
outrage it's like this is the typical
thing the typical nonsense we have to
get excited about every day and it's you
know on that point is I got the book
yesterday really enjoying it so far this
is a good people might have seen Glenn
Beck was out we were smoking cigars he
was puffing out of a bong yesterday and
but there is this constant need to
politicize everything to be outraged at
everything and when it comes to Bert and
Ernie being gay of course the the
reasonable person would just say like
are you kidding me but but there is a
question to culturally why does every
friendship have to be gay now like you
know when guys are buddies they're like
oh man I that was a really fun last
night no homo no right or no I'm - we're
not getting you just you actually I'm
not gay it can be funny or whatever it
is weird that Bert and Ernie lived
together for so long yeah but what
happened to friendship why can't people
just be guys be platonic friends and not
everything be very sexual I don't know
how to limit say yes I think they can be
platonic I feel like I have several now
they may make a move on me at any time
so you might make a move on them I don't
know barrows and maybe we're setting a
week away from making a decision you
never know and it's like I don't know
like I I can understand like there's
part of me that understands this right
like if you if you've been around for a
long time and and in you're gay and you
feel like you haven't been accepted
you're looking maybe for cultural things
that you can kind of attach yourself to
but you don't get to force the creative
abilities of the people who created
these things I mean you know the you
know Frank Oz is
he came up with us and he he has an
opinion about who these people are
they're good friends you know it was at
a time in which we didn't try to force
sexuality and the kids shows children's
programming wasn't the target for gay or
straight sexuality that wasn't a great
place for it and I feel like in reality
everybody knows this right what but like
we have to wake up every day and to find
our reason to get through the day to
give ourselves a little bit of energy a
little bit of juice to make our lives
have a little meaning we got to get
something to get pissed off about and
you know that's nonsense it doesn't make
me happy
right I don't know anybody it does make
happy in the long term long run and I
would rather go back to a time in which
you know I have kids I have two small
kids five and seven and they're in even
though they don't think they watch I
don't think I've ever seen them watch
Sesame Street but like you know what's
the Michael Nolt show but they don't
want that this is we just put knowles on
repeat all day but and they learn a lot
they learned a lot but they're saying
interesting but you know it's it's I'd
rather have them that's something you
want to teach your kids you want to walk
through that journey with them you don't
need that talk to them by Sesame Street
all you know if they're gonna be taught
by a puppet I I'd rather have control of
what the puppet says you know right and
there is this part of it outraged
culture which is why are we always
outraged over these sex things the storm
you Daniel's yeah whatever I think in
part it's not because we've suddenly
discovered sex you know people have
known about sex for a long time
it's just that it's such a basic and
fundamental passion that we just focus
on it to the exclusion of other things
because we're not capable of thinking of
other things all people want to talk
about in politics is gay marriage gay
sex abortion Roe versus Wade this then
it's all and Donald Trump's flings with
porn stores it's all sex sex sex all the
time I think it might have to do with
people not reading books or not having
other interests we're not maintaining
other sorts of relationships right I
mean like it's it's hard to get people's
attention right you go into this books
are long they're hard
they've got words they're all over the
place there's almost no pictures and
many of them yeah it doesn't have any
pic oh you don't want to see the
pictures in glenn book yeah you never
want to see pictures of Glenn
so rule I always lived by but it's true
it actually takes time I think this
happens so much in politics right like
where you know you can go through hell I
mean how many times did you good week I
went deep into you know under the
Obamacare bill you're going deep into
all these like really in-depth you know
pieces of legislation that they're
passing and you get about halfway
through some of these sentences and you
you feel like you look up and let's just
everyone's like days they're bettin
they're on their phones they've they've
gone to you know they're playing you
know candy crush whatever they're doing
and sex can easily redirect that
conversation I mean you know the
Cavanaugh thing like they tried they
tried going down the road of well he's
you know what they tried they try to
portion more - I'm Ernie overturn that
right right like they went through all
no one was trying constant and they
weren't saying hey this guy doesn't know
the Constitution they weren't saying hey
this guy's not qualified they were like
hey you know 36 years ago this guy may
have done something at a party which we
don't know when it was or where it was
or you know who was there remember it's
like get rid of me in because that was
the only thing that could get anyone's
attention if you're talking about the
things the supreme court justice should
actually be judged on you get no
audience and it's frustrating you know I
mean I this happens way too much and it
happens on both sides at some level but
the media in particular like they will
take every donald trump tweet and try to
make the biggest thing in the world out
of it and it's like you know what is he
doing like they'll make this big thing
about how he's so easy on russia right
you know ignore his tweets ignore what
he says there's no more reactions and
his his inspirations he's been tough on
Russia sanctions all over the place like
tougher than Barack Obama much tougher
than a Barack Obama and you know there's
no recognition of that in the media or
at least it's very rare and I think it's
because well a tweet is like the
ultimate journalist lazy tool right like
we think about like journalism 20 years
ago you'd have to go to a place and you
have to find people who are there and
you'd have to ask them questions and
they blather on about nothing for a
while and then at the very end they
maybe say something that you have to
pull out for TV now go to Twitter search
key terms find someone who says they
were there put it on the screen your
quotes done you didn't have to walk out
of yeah that's right and I feel like
that's in that now or to the point where
even when something of the presidency in
the United States or any cultural issue
that just go on and they'll find a few
tweets to support their case
and that's it it's it's honestly just
lazy but it reinforces you know that
addiction that we were talking about
people are just bouncing back and forth
looking for them because outrageous lazy
anybody can do it anybody can pretend to
do it how dare you Barry I'm sorry I'm
offending all of the average Americans
and there I noticed this on Twitter III
can I'm perfectly happy going hard
fighting for your team fighting for your
guys not letting them railroad Kavanagh
you know being a pugilist punching back
twice a sword I'm all into that but one
should have some perspective right I
always find on Twitter if I'm genuinely
getting angry you have to get off
Twitter yeah you have to shut it down
nothing good will come of that but that
seems like it's the whole media cycle
now it's all of the certainly on the
left it's not true on the right as well
and so if if are now if our new cycle
has become outraged and tweets and memes
I want to focus on those last two parts
the tweets and the memes and the
Internet of it all hmm in the European
Union right they are debating the
important issues not Russia encroaching
on their borders not the Islamic
invasion or the 65 terrorist attacks in
the last four um none of that no that's
no no no they're gonna ban means they're
gonna ban internet memes this is a real
thing they're debating article 13 to
censor internet memes what is this about
well I mean they say it's about
copyright right and because you know if
you have an emo the office well then the
office really owns that still shot that
you're posting a moving print on I mean
but that seems to be just a scam right
like you know first of all I think we've
learned over the years that trying to
censor content on the Internet does not
go well you know you lose control of
your industry quite quickly when you do
that but this seems to have more of a
political motive motive right like the
you know they've seen the effectiveness
of this stuff it does it does move
people yeah and then in a way I think
going back to the previous conversation
it's sat right like you shouldn't be
moved politically by a meme but I think
I don't know that have you seemed like
really really really good me well
they're really really
yeah then I'm infinite well it's it's
it's kind of ridiculous right you should
be moved by a book you should be moved
by a Supreme Court argument you should
not be moved by a picture from Parks and
Rec what about the one of the guy with
the girl and he's looking at the one
girl be holding the handle you know
that's very convincing that's an
exception yes that is hard cases make
bad law I feel like our new constitution
should just be that picture and we
should just play it freedom on one side
is a mirror and that's just the whole
thing that means someone would read it
then it would be interesting but yeah I
think that like they've seen the success
of this and how they can get people to
you know move really quickly a lot of
times to ideas that weren't really
considered you know kind of in the
Overton Window of politics before right
and that's scares an organization like
the EU which I would argue should ban
itself and just go away right of course
right you know like that that would be
my idea but it's like they want to make
sure that they have got control they you
know these things that come up they're
gonna try to push them down however they
can you know that the closer they are to
control over these arguments the better
and more secure they feel and I think
it's connected to the outrage I think
the two are because we're the memes come
from the reason I really defend the
memes I don't know baby especially the
one with the guy in the girl
yeah well that one especially that one
is because they're funny and they they
take on political issues with humor they
might be shallow who might be partial
but they are funny and the reason that
they're allowed to be funny the reason
that the right is able to take a hold of
humor is because the left is so angry
and shrieking and pink hat oh you know
because they're doing that right now
because they are living in such a
fantasy we're allowed to make fun of
them and it and it works it's really
funny and so I see this move by the EU
which is the archetypal tyrannical and
you know like octopus body is as
representative of the left which is
trying to censor all of that censor that
humor shut it down shut down Twitter
account shut down conservative speakers
on campuses I don't think that works for
them in the long run I don't think that
censorship is a winning platform it
never is I mean a you know look at
Mubarak you know he shuts down
your internet and you know he's now no
longer there right I mean it's a polite
way to put it yeah that's one way but
it's true I mean I think like trying to
shut people away from ideas draws them
to them you know I think it's it's more
in the long run it gets you to a better
place if people are debating these
things in a you know in a way that had
creates more depth but you have to get
people in the door you know like we did
this going back you know you know I'm on
the Glenn Beck program as well and it's
like we know this is kind of the
philosophy of the show from it's very
beginning which was the fusion of
entertainment and enlightenment it's
like you go in there and like you're
gonna grab the people at some level with
being silly and having fun with these
things
but like I I would imagine a lot of
people came to real political positions
and understanding of our foundational
principles that started with memes you
know if you're 15 years old you're kinda
go freakin read the Constitution or I
don't care what Ben Franklin was yapping
about but if you you could get a meme
it's funny and then you kind of brings
you to you know a story and then it
brings you to you know something where
they Lincoln just something with a
little bit more depth than race on your
reading Edmund Burke exactly you're
right there I mean I think I do think
that that's a process that actually
happens now I have this tendency to when
these new things you know like when
Twitter starts it's like to me it's just
like why do you want to do 140
characters that seems ridiculous
I liked this is silly I mean at the
beginning when blogging started like
that was it was something that you kind
of would like mock and like it's the
same thing with talk radio and then the
mainstream media looked at that and said
that's stupid
but over time these things turn into
something real it really moves people it
can really engage people and then that's
positive as long as you take that extra
step afterwards where you actually learn
what the foundation is and you know
hanging out with you guys the last few
days obviously we've known each other
yeah longer than this week but it's been
so fun yeah it's really really going on
the show I always I always forget how
funny Glenn is too because I think of
Glenn is this kind of serious guys like
really really funny yeah
so we're because you're you're
everywhere you're on the news and why
matters you're on Glenn Beck program
where can people find you all over the
blaze what is the easiest way yeah
people go here now well I would
definitely if on Twitter what we're
we're there at world of Stu would be a
great place to go follow you know
obviously the Facebook everything else
but the blaze yeah news and white matter
Glenn Beck program every day and a
wonderful world of stew is another show
there's a lot of stuff out there that I
think you'd like on that as well so
check it out
all right Stu thanks for being here man
I appreciate it was awesome thanks good
to see you Salaam
that guy is so smart yes that's that's
really really tells me how to understand
all these really confusing news cycles
so when I wake up in the morning you
know so we're usually about 12:15 12:30
you know supposed to be at the Daily
wire Friday 10 minutes earlier when I
wake up one of the first things I like
to do is read a leftie puff piece I find
they're they because then I start
laughing in the day I start I start my
day with some joy and a mark walberg
likes to start his day working out and
praying that's one way to do it I like
to read Lefty puff pieces on New York
Magazine The Daily Beast voxcom so
there's a new one out today on Cory
Booker and this made me realize that
Cory Booker will never ever be the
President of the United States here's
the piece there are a couple points I
want you to notice here I want you to
notice one the difference between how
the left at the left-wing media which is
to say the mainstream media how the
media treat Democrat politicians and how
they treat Donald Trump and Republicans
the title is can I get a hug Cory
Booker's got a lot to give a lot of love
to give and he's betting that's what it
will take to win in 2020 Donald Trump
had a lot of love to give to according
to struck me Daniels you don't see those
fluffy titles for him that do you so I
want you to notice that I want you to
notice the treatment and then I also
want you to notice what a horrible
candidate Cory Booker is so so here's
just the first paragraph of the piece
anyone who thinks it's nothing but teeth
grinding paranoia and rank misery in
Washington these days hasn't been to the
office of New Jersey senator Cory Booker
these people are happy indeed his staff
are some of the cheeriest nicest people
you could ever hope to meet when I
arrived on a hot swampy morning just
before Labor Day weekend I'm greeted
with hugs and candy an exuberant woman
in a dashiki sits at reception what's a
dashiki well we'll get to that later
Kristen Lynch the communications
director greets me okay hugs me and
takes me to Booker's office where we say
hello to his chief of staff Matt clapper
who also hugs me Booker has not hugged
me yet but give
him time a young staffer comes in and
hands Booker a brown paper bag and tells
him she managed to score the last three
in the cafeteria from the look of joy on
his face I imagine a bag of
cheeseburgers but alas it's just celery
and carrot sticks in plastic deli
containers Booker is a vegan he opens
one up and munches on a carrot munches
on a carrot I am gonna hold my tongue
hold my tongue Michael that's what I'm
gonna do so where to begin where to
begin on the hugs and the love and the
dashikis so they're painting this
picture of him as this wonderful guy
because there is a portion of the
Democrats who want him to be the nominee
especially in New York and New Jersey
where Cory Booker is from and they're
angling for Cory Booker to be the
nominee you remember six years ago he
was defending Mitt Romney and he was the
moderate normal guy Cory Booker's a very
intelligent man by the way and and so
what Cory did then was he was trying to
be the moderate guy and then he realized
that that wasn't the ticket because his
party has completely gone off the rails
so now he's the crying guy with tears of
rage and I love you right and he thinks
that's going to help him it's not going
to help him moreover though I want you
to realize how totally isolated the
left-wing media has become the elitist
left-wing democrat base has become
because they actually think the New York
Magazine they genuinely think that
eating celery and carrot sticks is
likable I think Cory Booker thinks that
that being a vegan makes you likable
you're such a good person because it now
in many ways it'd be in a left-wing that
has become post Christian that has
become materialist in a certain way
they've adopted other religious values
like veganism or yoga to borrow Matt
Walsh's observation or this or that
you've got to serve somebody so even if
you're pretending to not worship God or
not be a Christian or whatever you're
gonna worship somebody you're gonna
worship humanity you're gonna worship
animals you're gonna worship the
environment you're gonna well you're
gonna worship somebody and that's what
they think is going to play this does
not
I look at who we just elected we elected
Donald Trump we elected a guy who takes
photos in private jets thumbs up well
he's chowing down on KFC and slurping
Diet Coke this is not going to play but
to them it does because they don't know
anybody who eats KFC they don't know
anybody who does this they I mean the
effete holes that these people come from
i I've seen it I mean I've lived in
coastal places I've gone to elite
institutions and they really believe
this this oh you know I I just had my
celery sticks mm-hmm oh I just love
hummus like huh I mean I like how much
as much as the next guy but oh yes they
would never consider eating like a
pudding cup you know who could never
they that does not play at all and
they're making another big mistake not
just on the style that they're choosing
but thinking that the election is going
to be a bad style in not policy this is
from later in the article Robby Mook who
was Clinton aid Robby the director what
Robby Mook who managed Clinton's 2016
campaign cautions against reading the
upcoming campaign as a battle over
policy issues so what hit what he thinks
with the left believes is that this is
really gonna be just about style that's
why cory booker is pretending to cry and
fight tears of rage and hold these weepy
little press conferences one he thinks
that style is gonna work because his
party is very feminized and all the men
are these little soy boys it doesn't
work nobody wants a man to behave like a
woman they might say that they do they
might pretend that they do they don't it
doesn't look good we just elected Donald
Trump who is slightly more
knuckle-dragging than Attila the Hun in
his public statements and people like
that they actually want that there there
might be other ways to do it but they
want a man to show strength and weeping
and crying and press conferences with
Liz Warren ain't gonna do that but to
Robby MOOCs point to the Democrats point
that this is gonna be about style and
not policy I think he's miss reading the
country I think they're totally miss
reading the country because they've
drawn the wrong conclusions from Trump's
election I hear this all the time for my
lefty friends New York friends they say
Donald Trump was elected in because of
his worst stylistic instincts because of
his worst statements because he's bad
bad
bad that is is not true that's what they
might conclude that but that's not true
from the Trump voters I know for the
Trump voters that I talked to and from
Ann Coulter wrote a great book about
this we're gonna be talking with Ann
Coulter soon Donald Trump was elected
for policy purposes he was he was he was
elected for the judges he was elected
for immigration he was elected for tax
cuts here's here's a little bit of
evidence for this by the way Donald
Trump four people say he has no
ideological warnings he has no beliefs
he has no policy preferences I don't
think that's true Donald Trump presented
a legitimately unique policy platform in
2016 he was talking about some of the
dangers of free trade no Republican was
doing that he was talking about
immigration in a very blunt way because
it's it's very fashionable for
Republicans to say oh we really have to
do something about immigration and then
give everybody amnesty and keep the
flood floods coming in and Trump said no
we're not gonna do that we're not gonna
give anybody amnesty and we're gonna
deport illegal aliens that was different
people were not saying that before Trump
he was offering a different policy
platform and he was elected for that
platform everybody that I talked to I
talked to a lot of people I travel
around the country there say all that
Trump he's really gotta lay off those
tweets but yeah I like what he's doing
that's what it's about and it's gonna be
about that and the Democrats are they've
whipped themselves up into the fantasy
what this election has become what the
2016 election has become and they're
meta-narrative in their in their
historical fiction it's not going to
serve them well if this is about policy
and it's going to be about an honest
debate and minoo one of the great
characteristics of Donald Trump is
people view him as a blunt talker that
he is he's he doesn't BS he tells you
what he's thinking and he's kept his
promises he's one of the few politicians
we've seen who's actually managed to
keep his promises in office that's why
we're all so shocked at him I think
that's what it's gonna be about before
we got to go this is really rough
because there's so much more to talk
about I've got to talk about James
O'Keefe in the deep State I've got to
talk about the novel solution to
Venezuelan economic crises and
starvation but we've got to just skip
ahead to the meaning of life I promised
you that we talk about the meaning of
life
at the Emmys which you didn't watch I
know for a fact you didn't watch them
some lady who I don't know was wearing a
Nike designed outfit on the red car
because who's gonna tell her message and
she sums up a lot of what the left and
maybe even parts of the center or
thinking right now in America and I want
to show the conclusions of her thoughts
and the errors of her thoughts here she
is
look at you sporty spice baby why you
were a knight I am wearing Nike to
applaud them for supporting Colin
Kaepernick and his protest against
racial injustice and police brutality
this custom Nike
absolutely absolutely wins come over put
some beads on it some Sparkle you know
how they roll
there's no good yes Kate Moss and DJ
Pierce Chanchala so when did you decide
to do this you know I was actually
swimming the other day and I was like
what can I do what can I do that's
meaningful
I'll wear Nike I'll wear Nike that is
the left there one there they're in
their swimming pool they're like sipping
on their chichi or something and they
said what can I do what can I do that's
meaningful
I'll wear Nike that's what they're
thinking they've got existential dread
they feel meaninglessness in their lives
because the worldview that they have
adopted and adopted militantly deprives
their lives of meaning and they say what
can I do what can I do I'll wear Nike
they end up with these absurd ridiculous
ways to try to give some meaning to
their lives also regardless of their
absurd politics this does remind me why
I like some showbiz people is it's just
they're so wacky they're just say and
then the drag queens came over and they
put beads on my yeah you know there's
just this kind of innocent sweet things
you I don't know she doesn't seem like a
political philosopher exactly so perhaps
she can be forgiven some of her her
political ignorant but that really
highlights everything you know the hosts
at the Emmys the SNL guys
one of the jokes was they said you know
white people never thanked Jesus they
never thanked God in their acceptance
speeches the only white people who
thanked God in their acceptance speeches
are Republicans and X crackheads and
this got a ton of outrage they everyone
was so upset
show me the lie show me the lie show me
the white person who thanks God in his
acceptance speech who isn't a Republican
or an X crackhead I can't find one I
don't know where it where is he this
gets to a real point about the modern
left which is that they've deprived
themselves of meaning they boo God at
their National Convention they remove
God from their platform they try to
remove God from their platform they
don't have a meaning on top of their
life so they have to find it in
ridiculous places they're looking for
love in all the wrong places that's the
problem if you want the cure to outrage
first of all take a look at the man in
the mirror because you might be
complaining about everyone else on
Twitter being outraged but take a look
at the man in the mirror especially if
you're on the Left these days but also
then look up you know look up the people
who I know we're at that back stage
yesterday with Glenn and ban Andrew and
Jeremy everybody and we were all kind of
laughing about politics and having a
good time and it occurred to me all of
us believed in God
all of us have pretty we have I think
every one of us has different religious
views but we all have a religious
grounding in God in a theistic vision
look at that look at if you make an idol
out of politics you're gonna be really
really miserable and you're gonna make
yourself look ridiculous and you're
gonna wear a Nike shirt to the Emmy
Awards and that's not gonna age very
well don't do that that isn't that
shouldn't be your God there is there is
something more and if you look up your
you're gonna have a better time in
politics and you're gonna make yourself
look less absurd okay that's the show I
know we're running late too bad I don't
care we've got a lot more get you mad
about questions and we're gonna do that
tomorrow we've got some great interviews
coming up people that I'm talking to I
don't know maybe Ken Starr I don't know
I don't know maybe a lot of people
coming up so tune back in in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
Michael Nolt she'll see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael noland is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018